[Музика]
маніакально, і він би
звався нагаші, який вона відчуває, дійсно кричить
більше і там знають страву важко
Деніелс парафія знала мене портлетки на
добрий вечір
ми спробуємо Бабу видалити
запис про придбання наркотиків Аня найбільше
відповідні терміни тому
Ішіта вкрала частку на телугу, але
блондинка-мусульманка Стюарт Гугу не так, це дуже
Емма ввечері вона зіграла мене на катарському
вуду shim, більші сумніви зникли
[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія лешка давайте
почнемо
і я хотів би привітати мого дуже дорогого
гостя сьогодні привіт Наталія як ти
дуже добре дякую привіт привіт привіт
всім гарно
і привіт Гарріку як ти сьогодні підійди
до дошки добре так як ти
сьогодні добре
о супер добре добре так сьогодні  ми продовжуємо
говорити про фільми і
сьогодні опишемо фільм добре, але перед цим давайте
перевіримо домашнє завдання, щоб учні
мали написати діалог,
уявімо, що це приклад нашого
студенти, і у нас є фрази, які нам
потрібно заповнити, я допоможу вам не
хвилюйтеся, тож давайте подивимося, про що йдеться,
так про що фільм так, ми
хочемо подробиць,
я віддаю перевагу фантастичним фільмам номер три, звичайно,
чому б
не наступний  що відбувається ми хочемо
побачити наступний розклад
ах мені дуже подобається він і останній,
хто в ньому знімається, тому ми хочемо почути
головну роль, одна фраза тут додаткова, яка
нам не потрібна, тому що у нас є п'ять
фраз і шість  варіанти давайте почнемо добре,
послухай мене,
привіт, Сандра, ти хочеш піти
зі мною в кіно сьогодні ввечері, це звучить добре,
і ми повинні додати щось, що Сандра
запрошує в кіно, тож що, на вашу
думку, є найбільш підходящим, щоб мені здається
, що ми  я збираюся обговорити
розклад,
хто не буде прогресувати, яка пісня так
точно, дякую Наталія, тому наступна
пісня, яку я напишу на
дошці, щоб відчути, яка з них так,
що там показують, показують, показують
їх шоу  море скандалів з ним
це D ми можемо'  більше не використовую D добре, давайте
йти далі, так як ви думаєте, вибачте, але
я не захоплююся романами, тому я не люблю
романтику, добре, що ви думаєте
, що буде наступним Гаррік
так, я віддаю перевагу фантастичному фільму Наталія,
погоджуюся так  так, правильно,
так що номер два це B ну наскільки поганий
великий і потужний, хм, я не чув
про нього, тому я нічого не знаю про
фільм, і вони хочуть знати деталі
, подивіться, що це за човен так, що це таке
про молодець, це цифри, причина,
добре
, подивіться номер чотири з фразою,
а наступним буде Джеймс
Франко, тому якщо це ім'я актора,
що підходить, хто починає з так,
добре, хто в ньому знімається, сміється і
останній о ла ла ла ла і наступний
я теж, то що, на вашу думку, є найбільш
підходящим серед цього, у нас є C або EE так,
Brava
Gauri добре ідеї так, так що бачите, нам не потрібно знати,
чому б ні, але насправді це так  одна з моїх
улюблених фраз, звичайно, чому б не піти
в кіно, добре, тож давайте подивимося
на ці прикметники  tives позитивний один хороший
чудовий цікавий навчальний фантастичний
веселий або смішний і музика що
дивовижний і кумедний забавний означає, як
часник
Віджая так добре, чи знаєте ви всі
слова, крім музичної освітньої
фантастики, це зрозумійте правильно, так що
добре, непогано, це добре, добре, і  з
це щось більш негативне
дурне дурне, що це за хибний.
мм-хм, я дурний так, абсолютно
правильно
жахлива
вода явно жахливий шок явно
жахливий шок явно
нудний турбо нудний зелений ну так заколот
заколот тож чи можеш ти думати про що-небудь,
що може бути дурним, що може бути дурним,
дурне запитання, як дурні запитання,
що ще може бути дурним будь-які приклади
дурні запитання
дурні дурні сюжет за сюжетом  так ось або по-
дитячому, ймовірно, правильна історія може бути
жахливою дійсно жахливою,
все йде в історію правильно, добре, якщо
ми  подумайте про навчальний, що може бути
освітнім сюжетом, о Господи, ідея ідея
гарна найбільша ідея Гарі чи може фільм бути
навчальним так, звичайно,
Брава, добре, тож давайте опишемо різні
типи фільмів, подивіться на
прикладі, що ви думаєте про
документальні фільми, що таке  цей
документальний фільм природна і реальна ситуація
життя і доля хороші інші освітні
документальні фільми так так, звичайно,
так що ви думаєте про документальні фільми
я вважаю їх нудними
я віддаю перевагу науково-фантастичним грі наукова
фантастика багато екшн, як Джеймс Бонд,
як ці речі добре, що вам подобається
дивлюся Alice rulers вони фантастичні
що ти думаєш про комедії Наталія
мені подобаються я вважаю їх дуже хорошими дуже хорошими а
ти Ерік що ти думаєш
про комедії дуже добре дуже добре дуже
цікаво і смішно правильно я зірка
комедій так супер зірка  комедійний актор
хороший а
фільми жахів ти любиш
дивитися фільми жахів я ненавиджу
фільми жахів жах страшний жах я не
помру я  не люблю фільми жахів, добре
зроблено, зараз є завдання для вас, скажи, що у нас
є мурахи, які ви повинні позначити їх,
я даю вам десять секунд, а потім ми
збираємося разом перевіряти, готуйтеся,
давайте перевіримо разом, тому номер один, що
є  подивіться на шоу що це
за шоу перша буква G і
s подивіться це актори
грають у гру так
ігрове шоу ігрове шоу ігрове шоу мм-хм
номер два що це за шоу
Хітчин так  ми впевнені, хто це
ви знаєте актора: наше шоу
Кулінарне шоу Коран Кулінарне шоу Бредбері
так це Джеймс Олівер, а це
кулінарне шоу номер C подивіться
з посольства, що це за фільм, з
якого воно починається  F так що це
за фільм цілий так Дякую
Наталія фентезі фентезі
так я ображений хворий так давайте з D
це тільки я ні значить так і який
тип фільму цей капітан я відповів
а найбільш фільм  будь-яка анімація
анімація анімація Мусульмани
[Сміх]
анімація  або мультфільм давайте
з E наукова фантастика
Браво італійська фантастична
наукова фантастика давайте з D про
тортури, тож почнімо з D тварини ні, боже,
ти знаєш G пам'ятаєш
документальний документ, ти робиш документальні фільми так
документальні фільми,
так що National Geographic це
документальне так, так  National
Geographic показує багато документальних фільмів,
добре, давайте рухатися далі, тому сьогодні у мене
буде урок читання, я покажу
вам текст, подивіться на текст і швидко
скажіть мені, про що йдеться, з
назвою фільму, добре, подивіться  текст
знайти назву фільму
Опис табу Наталя або Гаррік
готовий Наталя фільм Ready Steady Go
як називається фільм
знайди його в наступному ах ні так
назва фільму Хоббіт,
тож давайте прочитаємо текст і  ми
послухаємо текст добре, вам буде
легше, і поки ви читаєте
текст і слухаєте текст, зверніть
увагу на невідомі слова,
це слова для вас, добре, готово, ми читаємо  d
ми слухаємо Slocum Cheatham Verdi McGowan
і nobis Lola Okay
Хоббіт з бестселера на великий
екран
[Музика]
як The Hobbit несподівана подорож
виходить у кінотеатри, люди по
всьому світу стоять у черзі, щоб побачити його
з використанням нових технологій це  класичний
роман був оживлений «
Хоббіт» був написаний британським автором
Дж. Р. Толкіном, це одна з
найбільш продаваних книг усіх часів і
приквел до популярної серії «Володар кілець
», вона розповідає історію
молодого героя Більбо Беггінса.  хто йде на битву
з драконом, проте під час своєї подорожі він
знаходить кільце, яке назавжди змінює його життя
за допомогою відзначеного нагородами
режисера Пітера Джексона Хоббіт
вийшов на великий екран, сюжет приведе
вас в захват, а фотографія вразить
вас  знято за допомогою спеціальних камер, які
знімали кожну сцену вдвічі швидше, ніж
стандартні фільми, це означає, що замість того, щоб
бачити 24 кадри кожну секунду, глядачі
бачать 48, результат виходить набагато плавнішим і
чіткішим.  уявіть, що більше, кожна дрібна
деталь фіксується, що робить фільм
набагато реалістичнішим з додатковим бонусом у вигляді
3D, фільм неймовірно реалістичний і
дуже вражаючий для перегляду завдяки
успіху таких фільмів, як «Хоббіт»,
схоже, що технологія високої частоти кадрів
тут залишиться такою  Ласкаво просимо в нову
епоху кіно, яка перенесе вас у
таку реалістичну подорож, що це наче
потрапити в інший світ
добра
[Музика],
тож дозвольте мені допомогти вам, давайте зосередимося на
словах Я впевнений, що ви знаєте слово
бестселер правильно так, Алан  це дуже
популярно і вгорі, так великий екран,
але скажи, бабуся, так, у нас є великий екран,
чи є великий екран так, це
великий екран,
не маленький, неочікуваний і розширюйте його
блискуче, так, раптом автомобіль,
так, неочікуваний репертуар так  ми маємо тут
несподівану подорож пацієнта як Деніел
так, але це інше
несподівана подорож загорнута OVA полірування
ти нічого не планував і сподіваюся, що ти підеш
у подорож
реліз фільму випущено пісню
випущено,
продовжуючи ні Наталія, у вас є нова
пісня, і ви робите, і ви випускаєте її,
щоб показати її глядачам так, щоб у
вас був новий фільм так, абсолютно правильно,
будь ласка, ви можете випустити книгу, ви можете
випустити пісню, яку ви можете випустити  фільм
по всьому світу люди стоять
у черзі, багато людей стоять
у черзі, так що так - Челсі стоїть у
черзі до нашої благодійної організації статусу, тому,
наприклад, люди стоять у черзі, щоб отримати
ваш автограф
так, вони стоять у черзі, це неправильно
залишатися на повороті ні ні, ні стояти в
черзі, ти знаєш, і це насправді одне
з моїх улюблених слів q подивись у
нас тут так, у нас є п'ять літер,
але ми вимовляємо це як слово, як одну
букву Q q так подивіться  що це
ти і слово qu це те саме,
що правильно
цікаво, ми вимовляємо, що ти дієш як
одна літера так постав черга автор ближче
так мені шкода, що ти є автором своїх
пісень, наприклад, так, давайте перейдемо до
приквелу, давайте погуляємо  подивись на це
речення, отже, це одна з найкращих
книг усіх часів і приквел
до популярного «Володаря кілець», ви запитали
мене про «Володаря кілець» і «
Хоббіта», так, Хоббіт насправді є
приквелом так, папа, який читає Асторію так,
серйозно серйозно  епізод що таке битва
Я впевнений, що ви знаєте це слово
так битва, у нас сьогодні битва, мені подобається,
тому ви віддаєте перевагу, Наталія переможниця, ми
відразу погоджуємося, так, так що
відзначений нагородами Оскар - це
нагорода, яку варто виграти так, ви  маю будь-які
слова я впевнений, що у вас є багато нагород ні
я працював, оскільки ми не Оскар, але будь-які
інші так у цій країні так, що з
тобою, Гарріке, у тебе багато нагород
ні Роді так, звичайно, так що Хіт
подивіться  у реченні кричить так,
хто саме він потрапляє на великий екран, тож
це наступний знімок, тому камера зняла
вас, шпигун, мала зніміть сцену зйомки так,
так, так, так, так, це
швидкість, мило поцілував, правильно, стандартний
стандарт, ви знаєте цей кадр  є фр  ee
yes
Odin Catterick кадр добре в історії
ми маємо 24 кадри, і вони перетворюються на 84,
так що це максимуми гідрат кадр
гладкий гладкий гладкий це щось на зразок
того, що Ankita kiiied його так рух
пощастило так
крихітні деталі о, так, дуже маленький
час, добре
реалістичний  ні, це виглядає досить міцно так,
додатковий бонус, це як додатковий синонім,
щоб додати його
додатковий додатковий бонус, тому сьогодні більше ніж
бонус  реалістичний
реалістичний реалістичний реалістичний так і крок
у крок у крок усередину так, щоб ви входили
всередину добре зараз у мене є запитання
щодо історії, тому нам потрібно відповісти на це,
будь ласка, дайте відповідь на запитання, яке ми
збираємося разом перевіряти правда чи неправда
правильно чи неправильно добре  номер один
фільм заснований на романі правда так так
правильно
і давайте перевіримо з текстом
подивіться, ми маємо це Несподівана
подорож Хоббіт реле  у кіно та
з використанням нових технологій класичний
роман був оживлений, добре
Толкін так, автор номер
два Хоббіт був натхненням для
іншого фільму, правда чи неправда так так, яким
був фільм драми «Володар кілець»
так  так це було багато багато багато інших обертів,
але вони забувають помітити авторів так
номер три особлива технологія була використана
у виробництві фільму так,
звісно так, дуже дякую Гарі
це правда, давайте перевіримо текст тут,
фотографія вас вразить  це були
фільми з використанням спеціальних камер, які
знімали кожну сцену
вдвічі швидше, ніж стандартні фільми, тому це вдвічі
швидше, наступний у майбутньому всі
фільми будуть мати 48 кадрів в секунду,
правда,
так, це було майбутнє в майбутньому,
всі фільми ні  ні, це неправда, тому що ми
вже маємо це в тексті маємо лизати
це не в майбутньому це в Хоббіті
Хоббіт вже має його
подивитись це означає, що замість того, щоб бачити
24 кадри кожну секунду  onds перегляди вже
обман або 48 зараз маю мою нудьгу Убуд нехай
хтось наповнить мене так або людина
Каліф добре
і останній 3d фільми виглядають нереально так
і справжні 3d фільми 3d фільми виглядають нереально
так, це залежить від конкретного дня, але у нас
є слово нереально  тому це не так,
максимум так, це навпаки, тому 3D-
технології допомогли нам зробити це
реалістичним, як справжнім, але подивіться
додатковий бонус 3D фільм неймовірно
реалістичний неймовірно реалістичний, як справжній
фільм, добре, тому завдання для вас 5
речень  і нам потрібно знайти відповідь
5 секунд і давайте перевіримо, щоб молодший арт
Окунь написав, що він написав так
Хоббіт правильно номер 2 Хоббіт
про битву між ким було
так Більбо Беггінс і драконом номер
3 Пітер Джексон - це хто режисер  так,
брате,
що робить фільм реалістичним, так це використання
технології 3d 3d, яку можна
назвати технологією високої частоти кадрів, але
насправді технології придушення, а також технологія з
високою частотою кадрів номер 5 досягає
чогось  це
набуває пария ні Брайан Трімбл
популярність набуває популярності Наталія
я буду набирати популярності
Лора полярність набуває популярності Міа
так стає все відомішою все більше і
більше дуже добре так, тепер ваша черга
відповідати на мої запитання,
тому відповідайте своїми словами
яка спеціальна технологія була використана у
фільмі Наталія 3d 3d Керік безкоштовний висока швидкість
кадри висока швидкість безкоштовно добре що робить
фільм вражаючим їх плавають аплодували
так і 3d технології добре і актори
працюють добре лезо вісім різців так 48 48
48 кадрів 48 кадрів 48 кадрів повторів  48
кадрів 48 кадрів Браво,
як ви думаєте, як нова технологія
вплине на майбутнє кінематографа, як ви
думаєте, що нова технологія вплине на
майбутнє серіалу, звичайно,
це буде яскраво, тому розкажіть нам три речі,
які ви пам'ятаєте про Хоббіта
Наталія, три речі, які ви пам'ятаєте
про сім'ю Хоббітів, це хромована
купюра Більбо Беггінс,
дракони, дракон, він маленький, добре, він
невисокий і бореться з  у них є пляшка добре
дуже дуже багато поганого, як вони повинні
зберегти і задоволені Перстень Господа
добре, зараз давайте подивимося на якусь
словникову гру подивіться, у нас є
слова тут як традиційні добре, як
успішна книга, чудова раптова й додаткова
та  це синоніми до цього світового
синоніма Великобританії, тож давайте замінимо це
слово мінімум Хоббіт – це традиційний
британський роман, класика так, велике
дякую часник номер 2 Володар кілець
був дуже популярним серйозним добре сподобався
чим ми можемо його замінити ні  чистий так,
номер 3 Хоббіт був заснований на
успішній книгі-наступнику продавець
молодець Італія фільм був чудовими
спецефектами дивовижний так і номер
чотири герой робить досить раптово
відкриття раптове редагування
несподіваний неочікуваний граван italia
і останній дивиться фільм в 3d  це
додатковий бонус або бонус до боргу. Дякую,
Гарак, тому сьогодні була дуже гарна робота, чи
хотіли б ви подивитись «Хоббіта
Гарріка» так, звичайно. О, як хто
дивиться  Хоббіт, Наталя, ти хочеш, щоб
я не бачила приквел, тому я люблю
цікаве, зараз я цікавий - добре -
дивіться - дивіться добре, але будьте обережні
, коли кажете, що я зацікавлений, я
цікавлюся відомим цікавим так
Мені цікаво, я зацікавлений - дивлюся
цей фільм, щоб дивитися цей фільм, щоб дивитися
цей фільм,
і знову мені цікаво - цікаво
дивитися цей фільм,
дуже дякую, тому
наступного разу, коли я піду, настав час для домашнього завдання  щоб
перевірити вас, щоб підкреслити правильні слова
номер один, головну роль
персонажа грає Крістен Стюарт
номер два, цей фільм знятий найкраще або
певна Канада номер три Хоббіт
отримав хороші відгуки про троянди або субтитри від
критиків номер чотири
Сучасні фільми мають дивовижну особливість
технологічні блокбастери або ефекти
номер п'ять, фільм виходить у прокат
або знімається сьогодні, а останній з них
грає Сурадж Шарма або прямий шпигун у Life
of Pi
Наступного разу я збираюся перевірити, чи ви
готові,
на жаль, є  дзвіночок і нам
потрібно припинити урок дякую
дуже за урок це дякую дуже
дякую дякую мій партнер
ні ні ні Патріс - вона обдурила - Коста
Ана біля плити чудово б вона
намалювала, якби з Google kappa / їздила  у
мене ситуація клас lo Kiyoshi
підступність, яка вище мого вітаміну
e бо зацікавлений дивитися фіолетовий на iti
найбільш азимут chemo vitamin C з Nemo
виробник alamou good Біллі все ще makino
куля особливо моногамія pakka -
морська подорож новий халат повірить
шок  на рівні, коли вона почервоніла Аррас Бутаков
Беллуччі карма робити шоу в саду, і
його прийшла над кодом ідея, що Помона,
яка не відчуває, що я роблю це, демонструє
після того, як нова Тата повідомляє
пария до диверта в сторону, скажімо, що ви ходите з
думкою, що був карате Джастін розрив  його коліно
Слава відповідає 16, але все
це більше Yosemite Valley напевно
, це чудовий смішний Google - ну
дивовижний і що ще
фантастичний дивовижний казковий
[Музика]
ви